IN THE FOURTH GAME AND OFF WE
GO WITH THE THAT START FOR THE
BLACKHAWKS IN THE FIRST
2-0 CHICAGO, HERE AT HOME.
HE GOES.HAYES AND HE
SCORES.
BEFORE THE PASS OPENS UP THE SA
DENYING
CIRCLE BACK FOR JONES.
HE SHOOTS
ANOTHER BEHIND THE BACK  CLEANL
HAWKS ARE WITH IT.
REBOUND ANDD RADISH FOUND
NEEDS TO DEVELOP., KICKED OUT
OF THE AIR AND HE ALMOST SCORED.
BUT
FROST TIPPETT, HE THROWS
IT IN.
THING UP.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE BREAK AWAY.
AND THE GOES BACK.
ANOTHER SAVE MADE. VLASIC CAN H
PASS.
HAYES IS DENIED ON THE
GOING TO LEAD TO A POWER PLAY.
HERE IS THE PUCK PROTECTION
FROM HAYES.
HE 216 POUNDS.
ALWAYS PART OF HIS ARSENAL.
OUT AT CENTER.
AND HE NEARLY TIED ITEN
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THIS CLEAR.
THERE IS THE SHOT OFF THE POST
THE REBOUND WAS
IN THE WAITING SECOND.
JONES THROWING ONE HITER  SETH
GOT THE BLACKHAWKS
THE PUCK ON HIS STICK INSTEAD,
AND IT GOT SWALLOWED UP.
TRIES
HERE IS TOEWS DRIVING GOAL TO B
CENTERING PASS WITH A SHOT FROM
THAN THAT FOR THE BLACKHAWKS.
>> Mike: HE TRIES TO RECEIVE
OFF THE BEAD FROM KANE, ALEX
DEBRINCAT
DELETE PLAYERS TAKE ADVANTAGE. N
NEXT.
>> Mike: HE CANNOT CONNECT WITH
STROME  AND PHILADELPHIA RACES
BACK. ART HOCKEY FROM ALEX
DEBRINCAT.
>> Mike: SENTRY.
THAT KICKS OFF THE CROSSBAR IN
THAT WAS RILEY
STILLMAN